we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
this is an example of a lot of what's
wrong with this country now i'm going to
warn you guys i'm going to play
something that's pretty ugly
um if there's kids in the room you may
want to get them out or
whatever the case may be based on your
personal sensibilities on this stuff i'm
about to play a pretty ugly voicemail
that tells us a lot of what is wrong
with this country take a listen
hey dave i'm just calling because i
wanted to become a member
no i'm just kidding you i'm not a [ __ ]
just wondering if you ever listen back
to your shows and
realize how much of a shield you are
and a weak pathetic man i assume by
shield he means shill right i mean i
just i'm trying to figure that out
okay let me go back i missed just a few
seconds of that how much of a shield you
are
and a weak prophetic man just curious
there it is so as you can see
uh not a particularly substantive
critique
we get 3 000 messages like that every
day now not voicemails
right so you've if you've got to look at
email
tweets facebook posts instagram comments
and of course youtube and twitch
comments but 3 000
a day that are somewhere in the arena
of stuff like that these are not folks
you can talk
sense into so we've got to figure out a
way to win
despite them we're with them is just not
realistic
we've gotta win despite them and there
are a lot of them there are a lot of
them today on the bonus show we will
talk about west nile positive mosquitoes
found in texas what does it mean
we will also talk about morgan stanley
the company
will be banning on vaccinated workers at
their offices starting soon we'll talk
about why in the legal infrastructure
and russia wants to send cosmonauts
to china i'm sorry to the chinese space
station not to try
i guess they could go to china to the
chinese space station
we will talk about this possible new
outer space alliance and
again i mean as if we needed more
reasons to invest in space exploration
um maybe some of the right wingers will
get behind it because russia and china
are getting together on the issue all of
those stories and more
on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpacman.com and get instant access
i'll see you then